ah to Papapa Papapa
[Music]
is it okay to say he's a pickle yeah
this is an episode where Rick becomes a
pickle turned myself into a pickle Morty
what do you do about that
pickle wreck story I first heard in the
pitch for the episode and we just wanted
to do a sort of a Fievel goes west I
think is how I described it it became
exactly as complicated as it sounded
like it was going in this episode is not
only moving has to walk but he's running
and flipping and it's flying through -
okay there's probably at least 100
versions of that rat suit on the server
somewhere every single person had a shot
of that pickle rag the first designs of
the rats were a little too adorable
Rick's gonna have to kill a bunch of
these we didn't want him to look like a
plate that your grandma collect nobody
wants to see a bunch of cute rats dying
so we were like alright let's make it
gnarly looks just like mess them up were
really artsy arts the back a lot more
put some oils on him
got rid of some first and that was
necessary because otherwise you're
watching a triple murder innocent rats
for a minute
it's a gritty episode it's super violent
it's very personal and Susan Sarandon is
in it probably because her kids a fan I
don't think she was like I love what
should my next project me
everybody knew pickle Ric happening
tonight so be sure to subscribe to get
it there is a new round of that merch
giveaway - for the Zen monkey studios
but I love the way that first clip tees
up Dan Harmon's reaction is it okay to
say that he's a pickle in this episode
they've been doing a really good job
with these tongue-in-cheek
behind-the-scenes things but the part
where they actually start talking about
the character designs the plot the story
is really good when Dan Gutterman
mentioned Fievel goes west as the
impetus for Ric getting sucked down the
drain
I had this flashback raise your hand if
you actually saw that in a movie theater
or on home video because that was early
90s so that was still prime VHS
territory but when I heard that I didn't
immediately remember the plot I had to
go back and double-check like what
happened during Fievel goes west what
did they do during that because
typically the stories are about mice who
go up against really evil cats using
really complicated Rube Goldberg
contraptions like they find ways to
fashion themselves really big weapons
out of human size think so I was like
maybe he's talking about that but then I
rewatched part of it in context with
this and was like oh he's just talking
about the part where Rick gets sucked
down the drain because during Fievel
goes west they get sucked down a drain
and that's how they end up on their way
to America but blast from the past
because I haven't seen that movie in so
long
and I do love the idea that they tried
to dehumanize the rats as much as
possible like you have your Disney
version of rats that look really cute
they have the Disney eyes but because
this is Rick and Morty and Rick is just
going to mow through all them they're
like okay we want you to really hate the
rats so we're going to make them look as
evil as possible while he's in that rat
suit and that's probably one of my
favorite lines from the episode so far
oh that pickle has a rat suit early
prediction is this episode winds up
being one of the fan favorites from the
season there's 10 episodes total so I
still think there's a couple episodes
that will surprise us and be like extra
awesome but let me know in the comments
what's your favorite moment from season
3 so far and what will happen is is just
like normal I'll post my Game of Thrones
episode tonight then I'll post my Rick
and Morty Easter eggs and references
video Monday morning so congratulations
to the latest merch giveaway winner
doubt the new please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details while you guys
wait for everything click here for more
pickle rick promo
and you can click here for brand-new
Game of Thrones thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
Oh